Jean-Michel
vous n'avez pas vu un chien madame
une dizaine de jours là je suis parti en
vacances je reviens il est plus là il y
a du jour vous c'est là 10 jours je l'ai
laissé là quand il y a une dizaine de
jours je suis parti en vacances
11 jours pour être
honnêtement je le mets sur l'autoroute
je me suis dit là je vais le mettre
sur l'autoroute
c'est Monsieur non non monsieur monsieur
s'il vous plaît monsieur
voilà
voilà vous avez non pas du tout mais là
il a senti que vous vouliez pas le
prendre et pourquoi vous marquez alors
supplément chien 4 francs mais c'est
dans le règlement mais si j'en prends
non non mais vous l'enlever parce que je
vais avoir du poil partout j'en veux pas
attendez c'est vrai que c'est plus la
mode le poil partout voilà vous l'avez
stressé la pisser
doucement doucement
[Musique]
ça y est
excuse-toi tout de suite auprès de la
dame désolé
il s'en va
regarde maintenant ce bordel qu'est-ce
que tu fais Titou Titou viens ici
[Musique]
n'était pas une vraie stature alors
pourquoi pourquoi il a pissé son truc
alors tu dégages
[Musique]